at what point did you decide to paralyze
the events of books four and five linked
it is well I don't remember a precise
date or time or anything you know it was
once again a case it has happened way
back with Game of Thrones when I I split
off Clash of Kings where the book was
getting longer and longer and there was
like no end in sight and I was faced
with a book you know the dance with
dragons and storm swords before it
really physically about as big as any
publisher cares to publish and and even
there some publishers don't care to
publish that book you know I only get
away with it because my books are very
successful so they they cut me a little
extra slack but a new writer who
delivered a 1500 page manuscript would
be promptly told by their publisher to
cut 300 pages or something like that if
not 500 pages so when my book start
getting up 1,300 1,400 1,500 pages in
manuscript I start seeing how far off is
the ending and in in the case of a dance
with dragons which was the book I
thought I was writing at that time um
I'm passing Storm of Swords in page
count length and I've hardly started
some of the storylines yet I mean you
know I don't write these characters in
the order in which you read them you
know I don't I tend to stick with one
character so I may write five or six
Daenerys stories or or and then switch
gears and write five or six Furion
chapters so there's a result I can wind
up with thousands of pages of
manuscripts in which I haven't yet
written anything about say brand which
was actually the case in that case with
with with feast for crows when I did do
the split I I hadn't written a word
about brand and that
in that book yet but I had I had
Daenerys stuff almost pretty pretty far
along I had Tyrion across the Narrow Sea
and down the river as far as volantis I
think I and I was gonna break him there
in volantis and continue on to the next
book but there were other people that
I've hardly started I had to do a lot of
work at the wall but I had all the
king's landing stuff pretty much as
you've seen it the Cersei stuff to Jaime
stuff all of that so at that point I was
wrestling well with for one thing the
fans and my publishers both were howling
for a book and it already been it
already been five years and I'd missed
several deadlines I kept promising when
I was going to deliver the book you know
I'm I'd originally in a crazed excessive
optimism had to hope to deliver Dance
with Dragons in 2002 so it could be
published in 2003 so now we're into like
2005 and it's still not out and it's
still not finished and it's not even
being close to finished and I could
sense the impatience from my readers and
from my publishers and you know
rightfully so
so I and the book is so long you know
well what do I have to do what are my
choices well one I can make severe cuts
I can eliminate hundreds of pages what
I've written here and try to bring it to
a thing but I didn't like that thing I
liked what I'd written to I can split
the book into you know I can just sort
of end a book where it is I got 15 under
pages let me send it in and say here it
is published it and some characters
there'd be big stories some carriers of
the other stories but then it dawned on
me that I could split the book but I
could split the book geographically
split the book not not chronologically
but geographically by character taking
out and publishing the story lines that
were finished some of them required a
little more work I had to wrap them up
and complete and moving to Narus who
after all was on another con
and moving the stuff at the wall you
know - to the next book and that seemed
to me to be the best solution to this
day I don't know that it was necessarily
an ideal solution but I still think it
might have been the best solutions of
the of the options that I had given
given the circumstances that existed at
the time but it's hard to tell you know
some people like it some people did if
you combine I mean you can still create
the book that would have been I supposed
by taking feast for crows and dance with
dragons and interleaving the chapters
chronologically but of course what you
get will is a book of prohibitive size
that will be the size of the OED and
you'll probably need a magnifying glass
to read the print in it and with so many
characters if somebody story lies that
you will lose a certain amount of focus
you know the the way the books are
structured now feast at least is a
strongly focused book at so much of it
takes place around Cersei and Jaime and
the events at King's Landing you know
with a few sidebars but the King's
Landing thing is really the heart of
that and then with Dance with Dragons
the focus is much more on Danny and on
the wall and on the characters making
their way toward Danny so I think two
books would a stronger focus was
probably better than one enormous Lee
huge book with 27 viewpoint characters
and all these stories going on it was
but you know that's that's you pays your
money takes your choice here and
opinions may differ that's that's why we
have these reviews and debates and
panels and all that to argue these
points next
hi you've talked about how looks very
big and expansive and well I'm just a
always thinking and I read them is
they're also very very detailed yeah she
wanted to ask you about that really how
you managed tough so we going on the
background whether it's more lunch Rabin
or some noise being made all these
little details that really make the book
special perhaps well the devil is in the
details they say I love the details I
think the details make the books
immersive and that's what I want as a
writer and that's also one I want as a
as a reader when I read a book it's
almost gets into a lecture that I
sometimes give it writers conferences
but let me let me just touch on the high
points of it here you know why why do we
read fiction what what is it that
attracts us to reading a stories about
lands that that don't exist in people
who don't exist in conflicts that never
happened what's what's the the appeal of
fiction to my mind it's vicarious
experience I I think we live through
fiction you know I look back on the
books that I read when I was young
Lord of the Rings you know I remember
the Council of Elrond
I remember Sam and Frodo making their
way across the the plains of Moria I
remember these events almost as if they
happened to me I remember the fog and
the Barrow Downs these things have have
become part of my memory now I read
these when I was like 12 or 13 years old
I don't remember what I had for dinner
the night that I read about the Council
of Elrond I don't remember who sat
behind me in my junior high school class
or who's that in front of me or
I'd even have to think back to try to
figure out who the hell the teacher was
and I probably wouldn't be successful so
which of these is really part of my life
which isn't as I live not to get all
existential well I think it's the things
that we incorporate it's the things that
we remember we all of us as human beings
are sums of our memories and our lives
when we when we live our lives and we
reflect our lives vicarious experience
can be just as important as real
experience and that's why I've been
known to say that a reader lives a
thousand lives before he dies while the
man who does not read lives only one and
I think that's true you know as a reader
I've climbed mountains I've visited
other planets I've I've doped at a
bottom of the sea I've sailed the
Spanish mane and for pirates I loved a
thousand beautiful women
I've died I've had children I've had all
these experiences that I've never had in
real life but and yet these they're
they're part of me and they've made my
life immensely richer so that's what I
want to do for my reader I want when you
you're finished with my books I want you
to feel that you lived those books not
that they simply read some words on a
page so I want to immerse you in the
world and details are part of that
details are probably the most essential
part of that you know you you read some
of these modern writers and and they let
page turners the John Grisham's of the
world the James Patterson's of the world
there's nothing but dialogue they almost
read like screenplays you know two guys
talking in an office they never describe
the office they never describe what
they're doing you know a guy walks into
a bar you never see the bar I mean there
are bars and bars there are foreign bars
and their dive bars in there every bar
is different and and some bars are
unique I don't I don't want that kind of
fiction and I don't want to give my
readers that kind of fiction I want you
to see the place and smell the place and
taste the food and I want it to be as
real as if you were living a book and
that's why I I put so much detail in and
I recognize that this is not for
everybody this is
you know some people do not value that
in fiction some people and I've had
people tell me that they they skim over
all the details all that boring
descriptive part I don't want just get
on with the story you know well fine but
those people can read James wish them
you know I mean there's lots of readers
writers out there for those people who
don't want the immersive experience who
obviously get something else out of
their fiction then then what I want out
of fiction and what I'm trying to
provide to my readers so does that cover
it I hope it covers it like that with so
many complex characters how do you keep
that timeline straight so that works
with increasing difficulty the timelines
in dance with dragons drove me mad you
know trying to figure out I mean it's
it's it's not just a question of keeping
a calendar and all that there there are
dramatic demands to you know in terms of
the pacing of the book you want certain
certain events to come before other
events and you want to build a certain
climaxes and you don't want two things
stepping on each other's toes he was
there happening on different parts of
the world so I was always wrestling with
the winter what I called the Meereenese
knot when in in dance with dragons which
was the the order in which certain
people should arrive at marine and and
where events in marine should be when
this character arrived and where things
should have progressed to when this
character arrived and has this turn or
twist happened yet and rewriting it and
changing it and and I kept doing it
saying no this doesn't quite work
because now works for this character but
then this character sort of out of it
and it's sort of anti-climatic when he
shows up I got to get him there earlier
oh no but that that means this thing
doesn't work anymore so it's it's
challenging it's challenging so you know
I'm I'm a you know just kill a bunch of
these guys and that'll just simplify
things no end